[Music]
on this tuesday night manitoba's dire
diagnosis hospitals buckling cases
surging and more help
is on the way there's hundreds of people
in hospitals struggling for their lives
right now
while bc unveils its plan to return to
normal by september
what's changed one year since george
floyd's murder
and we all said enough has there been
progress
in racial justice the olympics versus
the virus
fresh support to keep the games going as
criticism grows
it's going to cost lives and covet
climbs to new heights
the outbreak at mount everest
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with two different pandemic
realities playing out in this country
across most of canada the outlook is
improving by the day including in bc
the circuit breaker restrictions that we
put in place six weeks ago
have accomplished what they set out to
do a light that we've been talking about
for weeks and weeks now
is at hand
bc laid out its reopening plan today
we'll have more on that in just a moment
there and in alberta ontario and quebec
infection rates are dropping steadily
vaccinations are accelerating
hospitalizations are dropping and
restrictions are
easing except in manitoba it is still
dealing with a surge in new infections
and people
are becoming seriously ill hospitals in
manitoba can't handle them all
23 critically ill covered patients have
now been airlifted hundreds of
kilometers away to hospitals in ontario
doctors say other manitobans waiting for
non-covent urgent surgeries
have been left to suffer it is clear
that cancers are progressing and are not
being operated
on people who have aneurysms the
aneurysms are bursting at home and
people are dying
six patients have already died on the
cardiac surgery wait list
the manitoba government did extend its
ban on outdoor social gatherings
until saturday doctors though say that
doesn't even go close to far enough
they want a complete stay-at-home order
imposed immediately
brittany greenslade has our top story
tonight
as quickly as new beds in manitoba
intensive care units are created
they're being filled even faster people
who are currently on ventilators
or who are unable to talk because
they're gasping for breath they're on
oxygen
they're lying on stretchers in our
emergency rooms icu capacity has
increased by 150 percent
but it's still not enough to handle the
surge hospitals
are being stretched to the limits right
now
there's hundreds of people in hospitals
struggling for their lives right now
the federal government is sending help
including 12
critical care nurses within the week the
government of canada is preparing to
deploy additional federal
health resources including medical staff
to the canadian red cross and the
canadian armed forces
the armed forces will support vaccine
rollout
in 23 indigenous communities in manitoba
in the first three weeks of may 170
patients have been admitted to the icu
more than triple last month's patients
these patients are critically ill
they're younger and younger and what is
tragic and what is heartbreaking for the
staff these
patients suffer with their illness alone
alone and for many now hundreds of
kilometers from their loved ones
23 manitoba icu patients are now spread
out
among eight different ontario hospitals
others could be on the way to
saskatchewan within the next
24 hours and north dakota is on standby
just imagine for a moment what that
would be like to have a loved one put on
a plane shipped to another province or
state
and you might never see them again
surgeries are once again being delayed
creating major problems for others who
are also being sent out of province for
treatment
there are people now are waiting to have
their spines operated on
that are losing control of the bowels
and bladder and becoming paralyzed
and in fact the province has now started
transferring these patients
to u.s institutions for surgery
it's a dark tunnel manitobans are trying
to find their way out of
tuesday a group of doctors called for a
stay-at-home order and the closure of
non-essential businesses
while some public health orders are yet
again being extended
it might not be enough to help a
collapsing health care system
brittany greenslade global news winnipeg
there is steady progress in getting
canadians vaccinated over the last five
days an average of 387
000 doses were given per day 52 percent
of canadians
have now had at least one dose 4.4
percent have been
fully vaccinated in british columbia
officials say there's been so much
progress with vaccinations and slowing
down infections
they are ready to begin reopening this
is indeed a good day and one that i've
been waiting for for a long time
as i'm sure many people in british
columbia have too
eric sorenson has the details on bc's
four-step plan to normal life
and how other provincial plans compare
more than 60 percent of adults in bc are
now vaccinated and with
covet cases and hospitalizations
stabilized the province is beginning to
reopen
personal gatherings can expand to
include five visitors or one household
organized gatherings outdoors can be up
to 50 people
outdoor sports return with no spectators
and indoor faith gatherings with limited
capacity
there's more but you can hear the relief
in the premier's announcement
we have made extraordinary sacrifices as
a province and as a people
over the past 15 months and nobody is
more excited
than the four of us dining indoors and
outdoors is back with up to six people
per table
fable diner is looking forward to
welcoming more staff and customers
i think people are wanting to go to eat
now so i think it's potentially could be
a great summer for the
for the industry bc is tying its
reopening not to dates but data
travel restrictions between regions for
example will be lifted when a threshold
of 65 percent of british columbian
adults are vaccinated
with more and more people getting
vaccinated every day
we can gradually restart our important
social connections
the businesses the activities that we
have been missing for so long
quebec is also reopening this week
starting friday the province's curfew
will be lifted and outdoor patios at
restaurants can reopen
i'm really proud of quebecers
so we're moving forward with our gradual
reopening plan
in bc and quebec the third wave crested
in mid-april
the covet case numbers now as low as
they were last fall
in alberta the wave peaked in may but
has dropped dramatically
since then in ontario the third wave
persisted with much higher numbers for
weeks
but for the vast majority of canadians
the trend is clear
the waves are all breaking alberta's
remarkable turnaround saw schools reopen
today in most of the province barely two
weeks after students were sent home
ontario has begun gradually reopening
starting with outdoor recreation that
saw hundreds of thousands outside on the
weekend
while you're out and doing more things
outside still stick to the household
still watch the distancing the masking
provinces are reopening on different
timelines
but for most canadians it is just a
question now of how quickly
normal life returns eric sorensen global
news
toronto ontario has recorded its first
death linked to the astrazeneca vaccine
the province's associate chief medical
officer says a man in his 40s died a few
weeks after getting his first dose
he developed a rare case of
vaccine-induced blood clotting known as
vit five deaths are now linked to the
astrazeneca vaccine in canada
the first ontarians who got astrazeneca
doses in march are now
eligible to book their second shot many
report a lack of clarity today around
the booking process
ontario has a stockpile of 45 000 doses
of astrazeneca that is set to expire in
about a week
there could soon be another covid
vaccine available for kids as young as
12
in canada modernist says a clinical
trial of its vaccine in nearly 4 000
kids triggered the same
signs of immune protection as it does in
adults
modernist says the preliminary results
show no cases of covid19 among kids age
12 to 17 who got
two doses four weeks apart and they say
the vaccine was 93 percent effective
14 days after the first shot side
effects are mild headache fatigue and
chills
modernist says it will submit the
findings to international regulators in
early june
right now only pfizer biontic is
approved for use in canada
on kids age 12 to 17.
now to the memorials and the marches
honoring and mourning
george floyd one year since he was
murdered the intersection in minneapolis
where it happened is still closed
it's from here that the outrage and the
impetus to end police brutality
emanated and spread all over the world
today floyd's family went to the white
house for a private meeting
with the president and vice president
the family described their conversation
as productive and say they believe the
president is
genuine in his concern
say his name george floyd
thank you all before leaving the white
house grounds floyd's daughter gianna
led a chant that raised fists for the
family members who could not be at the
meeting
biden has pledged to fight long-standing
racial inequality in america though as
jackson proskow reports
legislative action has been slow and a
warning some of the video in his story
is disturbing it's time
for a change as a celebration of life
unfolded in the city where george floyd
was murdered so we're going to have this
moment of silence
floyd's family met privately with
president joe biden
after walking the halls of power
pressing for change
people realize what's going on
in america and we all said enough
this was the moment one year ago when
many americans woke up to reality
wake up wake up 25 million marched in
the weeks that followed
the trial and conviction of former
police officer derrick chauvin
was the beginning not the end of the
fight for justice and equality
until this point is moot
we're still going to be out here erin
xavier wilson joined last summer's
protests in washington
one year later he's unsure many black
americans will ever see a different
reality
there's a lot that hasn't changed and we
have a lot still
left to go than to bring the same sign
out and make the same point
senators the biden administration has
pushed congress to pass the george floyd
justice and policing act
it's still stalled it would create a
national system to track misconduct
and certain legal protections for police
and focus on combating racial bias
people are having conversations about
systemic racism and policing
that they never had before all of this
points towards
a likelihood of much more broad change
law professor justin hansford believes
there's actually reason for optimism
thanks to the size of the movement that
erupted and the awareness created by the
video of george floyd's final breaths
and we're going to see if that is going
to be enough to
to totally create this environment where
people
like myself can feel safe when we're
interacting with police officers what
that change looks like
is still the big unknown for all the
talk of abolishing or defunding police
that has not happened instead some u.s
cities have taken concrete steps to
improve accountability
and redirect resources to training
mental health and community initiatives
changes that one year ago would have
been unthinkable
spaces like black lives matter plaza
here outside the white house are now
permanent installations but many
activists point out
this movement came precariously close to
not happening
except for that one brave bystander who
took and shared that video of george
floyd's final moments
and spread it around the world donna
all right jackson prosco in washington
thanks prime minister justin trudeau
is condemning the government of belarus
over its brazen detention of a
journalist who had been living in exile
the international flight he was on was
diverted by a fighter jet and forced to
land in minsk
trudeau called it outrageous and illegal
this was a clear attack on democracy and
on the freedom of the press
we condemn it and call for his immediate
release
we also condemn this kind of dangerous
interference
in civil aviation
the prime minister added canada has
existing sanctions on belarus and he
will examine
further options well the olympics have
found an unprecedented competitor
in covet coming up how the ioc is trying
to shore up support for the tokyo games
plus blocking bans new laws in florida
to prevent social media companies
from silencing politicians
an ultra marathon in china has ended in
tragedy 21 runners died when an
unexpected
storm hit but a shepherd is being hailed
as a hero for rescuing six other runners
the shepherd says he's just an ordinary
person who did an ordinary thing
he went to help when he heard shouts at
2 am he took
a group of runners into a cave and lit a
fire to keep them warm
and dry their clothes the race to the
tokyo olympics is running into more
objections
international spectators were already
banned from the games and now the us has
told its citizens to avoid all travel to
japan
it doesn't mean athletes aren't going
they'll all be fully vaccinated
but the surge in coveted cases in japan
has led to a flood of calls to cancel
the games
as crystal comancing reports the olympic
committee's view is
the games must go on
a ride to a park and ride the president
of the tokyo games is being briefed on
every detail
questions to her however focus on the
game being a potential vehicle
for viral spread mass vaccination
centers just
opened in tokyo and osaka as japan
struggles with a fourth wave of
infections
beds and ventilators are in short supply
in osaka
hospitals are overrun with seriously ill
patients
still international olympic committee
officials are championing the games
which are now less than nine weeks away
in this final stretch
our top priority continues to remain
on organizing safe and secure
olympic games for everyone not only do
the president of the ioc speak publicly
but in what can be seen as an effort to
galvanize support
the olympic organization also released
messages from
two high-ranking public figures sport
brings us closer as a global community
and the world of sport has been a beacon
of light
to kaido's fort despite the new u.s
travel warning
american athletes will be heading to
japan
and so will canadians
there are plenty who want the 2020
olympics
canceled including japanese citizens and
local
and foreign public health officials it's
absurd to have the olympics
at the present time i mean if you think
of the two
key features of the olympics they
involve a huge amount of international
travel
and mass gatherings roughly 80 000
people are expected to attend the games
a key to the ioc safety plan is to have
athletes vaccinated
three different vaccine manufacturers
have offered shots
to ensure that can happen crystal
gamansen global news
london
i had goodbye charlie why this lovable
viral video
is being pulled from youtube charlie bit
me
who can forget charlie the finger biter
it's one of the first videos
to go viral which makes this a piece of
internet history
it's been watched more than 880 million
times
but it's not going to be removed from
youtube because the family has
sold it as an nft or non-fungible token
for more than 760 thousand dollars nfts
are a growing trend in the digital art
world it's like a certificate of
authenticity stamped into a blockchain
and it's lucrative for those who own the
viral clips
well you just want to hear more of that
florida's governor wants to stop tech
companies from de-platforming political
candidates to prevent what's happened to
former president donald trump
companies like twitter facebook and
google which owns youtube
could face fines of 250 000 a day if
they permanently delete or ban the
account
of a statewide candidate for office the
fine is 25
000 a day for other candidates or
elected officials
in signing the bill into law monday
governor ron desantis
took a swipe at what he calls silicon
valley
elites silicon valley
thinks they know better than you so
their power
up to this point has effectively been
unchecked
um and they have used this power in
silicon valley to impose their
orthodoxies
and their ideologies on our public
square
it's the first such law in the united
states although texas is considering
something similar republicans have long
accused social media platforms of
censoring posts from conservatives
studies have found the opposite is true
that the platform's algorithms regularly
amplify
right-wing viewpoints in january then
president donald trump was banned from
facebook twitter and other networks in
the wake of the
january sixth attacks on the u.s capitol
building
cruise ships are still banned from
canadian waters but the alaska cruise
season is going ahead
thanks to a new u.s law allowing vessels
to bypass canadian ports
president joe biden signed the
legislation monday it allows
foreign registered cruise ships to
travel directly to alaska from the
united states without docking in bc
it's meant to be a temporary measure
canada is expected to lift restrictions
in 2022
bc port authorities expressed concern
about the law setting a long-term
precedent though
and premier john horgan is discussing it
with alaskan lawmakers
outbreak at everest up next covet 19
creeps up the world's
highest peak
kovid 19 has reached every corner of the
planet and now even its highest peak
mount everest is dealing with an
outbreak among climbers
at least 100 people are believed to have
contracted the illness at base camp
adding to an already dire situation in
nepal
the tiny himalayan nation had 247 new
cases per 1 million
people yesterday that's according to our
world in data
and that is higher than india and way
above
canada's 47 cases per million people yet
the lure of everest persists as mike
derolay reports those who seek the
summit may be contributing to the surge
in covet 19 cases
every climber has their own reason for
reaching the peak of mount everest
three years after suffering a heart
attack you could say edmonton's leo
naaman had something to prove
um base camp a month ago the 51 year old
was in high spirits
his dream was within reach and then 2000
meters shy of the summit
food poisoning sent him home i never in
my life
ever ever ever experienced something
like that that was three weeks ago
three days ago he reached out to his
expedition manager to see how he was
doing
the response left him stunned his son
testimony and said no
he is he's no longer with us he died of
cover 19.
after the 2020 climbing season was
cancelled due to the pandemic
nepalese officials issued a record
number of permits for this year
millions of dollars and a good portion
of the local economy was at stake
when naaman arrived in kathmandu he saw
the disregard for covet protocols
so he put ropes around his encampment to
protect his expedition
despite what officials were saying
there's always this secrecy
this uh it was always this uh you asked
the question hey how is coming
to know we're good we're good we're good
base camp is good base camp is good
and we now know it wasn't
for weeks climbers have been leaving
everest either because of an outbreak
or in an attempt to avoid it we have at
least 100 people
minimum positive for covet in base camp
and then the dark number might be
something
150 or 200. even with kathmandu
hospital beds and oxygen in short supply
nepalese tourism officials say
there's nothing to see rumors as this
man sees it
all this canadian climber sees is a good
friend lost to covid19
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this mural
in downtown halifax a tribute to nova
scotian crystal
thanks for watching bye